بدون شك انت يعني مفتون بهذا العالم وقال
لها ما اشتغلت ما اسرك الى هذا الحد
طبيعي مين من الحروف العرب او غير العرب
اللي هم شكلوا لالك نوع من الهيكل انه
فتحوا امامك شيء تاملت في تجربتهم وفي
منهم بيشتغلوا على الحرف بدون معنى يعني
بدون ما ياخذون نص له معنى مثل المهداوي
مثلا المهداوي يعني لا تقرا نص تقرا لوحه
فيها حروف صح اعطيك مقاربه مقاربه الصوت
يعني او الشعر الشعر هو كلام مفهوم له
تاويله لكن عندما يغني مغني الاوبرا هو
ياخذ اللغه الى مكان اخر صحيح فاذا نزل
مهداوي اخذها الى هذا ذلك يعني التعامل
مثل ما نقول البحتري هو شاعر خالص فايضا
يوجد حروفيون خالصون
صحيح لغه الحرب بمعنى جرد الحرف اخذوا الى
مواطن الحرف صار يقول قوله الخاص فتبعا
لكل شخص يعطي تاويل او يعطيه قراءته بمعنى
انه الحرف قادر ان يوصل رساله خارج اللغه
خارج اللغه يعني ينفك من اللغوي ويتحول
الى لغه الخط هو بالانجليزي لاين وليس خط
بالعربي للاسف عندها نقطه هي الخط بمعنى
الخط مستقيم اولا والخط بمعنى فن الخط في
الانجليزي يختلف هذا الشيء
فهذا مبحث مهم فيوجد عدم الحروفين اخذوا
الحرف بهذا الاتجاه بهذا الاتجاه ويوجد
ناس يشتغلوا على اتجاه الكتابه حرروه من
اسر المعنى في الكلمه اذا فينا نسميها هيك
يعني